one of the first things I did in my
first week was contact them to offer a
meeting we've reiterated that again
today I'm hoping to see them very soon
obviously we're keen to see what the
result of the ballot was but my door is
open and I look forward to meeting them
in the days ahead
so this is not something that's ever
happened before do you understand
the frustration amongst people who their
business is caring for people they don't
take this action like me well we usually
value the work that nurses do that is
why we've committed to the independent
pay-per-view body to accept their
recommendations in full 1 400 pound for
over a million workers we also last year
recognized the contribution of nurses
that's why nurses receive three percent
more than and other public sector most
other public sector workers last year as
well and they themselves say there's a
range of factors in addition to pay and
of course we'll be discussing that with
them but we also need to recognize that
these are economically challenging times
we need a strong economy in order to pay
for a strong Healthcare System and a
demand of 17 three times what most
people acceptable workers will receive
is out of stat with the economic
circumstances that we face
you say your door is open uh is there
these are people performing a vital
function are you going to offer more
well we'll obviously discuss with them
in terms of the the circumstances and
the issues that they're raising but we
have an independent pay-per-view body
for a reason to look at the issues in
the round and the various circumstances
of course it's not just about pay it's
about our investment in the nhss state
that's why we're committed to 40 new
hospitals it's about increasing the
number of nurses that's why we've got 9
000 more nurses this year than last year
we're also on track in terms of our
Manifesto 30 000 more nurses to our 50
000 extra nurses Target it's about
investing in Tech and a wide range of
things but in terms of pay itself we're
offering an additional 1 400 pounds
while the Trade union are demanding is
three times what non-public sector
workers will receive an increase of 17
000 and of course we have to be mindful
of economic stability and ensuring that
we have a strong economy because that's
the Bedrock through which we invest in
health but also the other public
services that we need and what about for
patients I mean we know obviously that
emergency services are going to be
staffed uh but what are you going to do
to ensure people still get the care they
need well it's important that we
recognize firstly that emergency
services will be staffed and that's
hugely important in terms of the impact
this will vary from trust to trust not
every trust supported the ballot action
so we need to look at our contingency
planning working with trust working with
NHS England in terms of those impacts
and that's why again my door is open
I'll be having further discussions with
them there's a range of issues that
they've raised but the key issue is one
of fairness we've offered 1400 pounds
we've accepted in full the
recommendations of the independent
pay-per-view body we gave an increase
last year above what most of the public
sector workers received and we also need
to recognize the economic circumstances
in which we currently famous
settled this so if you need to do
something that's going to change change
the situation maybe well as I say I
think a demand of over 17
a cost to the NHS of a further nine
billion pounds in terms of the agenda
for change is how to stack with the
economic circumstances that we face but
at the same time we recognize that
nurses do a hugely important job very
much valued that's why we're working
closely to adopt in full the
recommendations of the independent paid
body it's why we took the extra measures
that we did last year it's why we
invested in more nurses 9 000 more
nurses than last year it's why we're
investing in 40 new hospitals because
alongside pay is about our wider
investment in the NHS in its estate in
its technology and the number of Staff
alongside accepting the pay
recommendations in terms of the offer to
nurses